تم تعيين Elon Musk الآن للسيطرة على
Twitter ، وهنا بعض
الفائزين والخاسرين المحتملين عندما
يسيطر على الشركة ، فلنبدأ مع بعض
الخاسرين المحتملين ، أحد أكبر
الخاسرين هو Elon Musk بعد شهور من
محاولته إنهاء هذه الصفقة.
سيدفع علاوة على Twitter ،
سيرث شركة تواجه
عددًا من التحديات من
مشاكل الأعمال إلى الضغوط التنظيمية ،
ومن الخاسر الآخر هو أن موظفي Twitter من
المحتمل أن يكون هناك تغيير في المجموعة c
مع فقدان الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Twitter وظيفته
سيحصل على تعويضات كبيرة ، لكن سيكون هناك الكثير من
موظفي تويتر الذين سيتعثرون في
التعامل مع عدم اليقين من هذا
الاستحواذ ،
وخاسر آخر هو تعديل المحتوى
، أشار المدافعون عن المسك إلى أنه
يريد قيودًا أقل على المحتوى على
تويتر وقد أثار خبراء السلامة عبر الإنترنت
مخاوف من أن هذا قد يؤدي إلى
مزيد من المضايقات ، والمزيد من المعلومات
الخاطئة وغيرها من المحتوى الإشكالي الذي ينتشر
على المنصة الآن ، دعنا نصل إلى
الفائزين المحتملين.  إذا كان الفائزون هم
المساهمون في Twitter ، فقد
صوت مساهمو Twitter بالفعل للموافقة على هذه الصفقة ، فمن
الواضح أن هذا شيء
يريدون أن يكون سعر الصفقة الذي وافق عليه المسك
يمثل دائمًا علاوة كبيرة
على المكان الذي تم تداول أسهم Twitter فيه
وعلى الأخبار التي تفيد بأن المسك
تجدد النوايا في متابعة
أسعار الأسهم للصفقة ،
فائزًا آخر هو المحامون على حد سواء
Twitter و Elon Musk الذين عينوا بعضًا
من أفضل
محامي الاندماج والاستحواذ في البلاد وهم على
وشك الحصول على رواتب جيدة
ربما يكون الفائز الأكبر هو الرئيس السابق
أشار دونالد ترامب ، بعد حظره من تويتر في 2021 ، إلى
أنه بإمكانه إعادة ترامب إلى
المنصة والتخلص من الحظر الدائم
تمامًا إذا قرر ترامب العودة إلى
تويتر ، فقد يمنحه منصة
بالملايين لم يكن لديه منذ ذلك الحين.  تم
حظره من المنصة وقد يكون
له تأثير كبير إذا قرر
الترشح للرئاسة مرة أخرى وقد يحدث ذلك  ليس
مجرد ترامب مسك قد أشار إلى أنه
يريد التخلص من العصابات الدائمة على
Twitter تمامًا حتى نتمكن من رؤية
حسابات الفرقة الأخرى تعود إلى النظام الأساسي
أيضًا